when is the album coming bro because
you've been dropping so much heat so
many singles I mean I know you've been
you know you've been putting out a lot
of music so the body of work's got to be
on the way uh April 14th you know what
I'm saying it's gonna be my best body of
work matter of fact
um got plenty of plenty of music for
people it's like 23 and then I'm gonna
come with a deluxe so it's gonna be it's
gonna be a big meal for everybody it's
gonna be huge it's gonna be my biggest
album the deluxe is already like you
already got all the songs set aside yeah
something dope I saw you do recently was
you gave Lil Wayne literal flowers yeah
and I think that that was was sweet
because I do feel like most of the time
artists aren't really appreciated until
they're not here or until they're like
you know for sure that's the main thing
that was the purpose what was the
process like for you kind of growing up
and Lil Wayne is one of the most
influential rappers ever you know like
working with Wayne what was that like
for you man man it was like a dream come
true you know you grow up listening to
him you grow up seeing them you grow up
being inspired more so than you then be
able to share the same room with them
you know let alone have a song with them
in a music video I just feel it was kind
of bizarre so um it was something I took
heat up I was grateful for I let him
know all throughout the through the
night how much I appreciated him just
for him being himself because um he
inspired me yeah you know it was a huge
drink on true [__] when did you like
what did did you guys get in the studio
together or is that something that he
knocked out and sent back home no he
just sent it back over I got the verse
when I was like in Whole Foods and like
did you listen to it on the phone at
Whole Foods my um CEO won the records
call me he was like um yeah man we got
Wayne on this verse I said what I'm not
I'm what's up
reacted very loud you must have dropped
your kombucha man I had some dropped the
fruits I was checking out man it was I
had the whole store looking at me that's
what I used to call him fruit salad in
high school for yeah
shout out to Cyrus he liked that
nickname
um
by the way Whole Foods cut the [__]
check all right because I feel like
you're pushing a lot of a lot of that
lifestyle would send people the Whole
Foods to get the right food and [__]
they need to you need to get an
endorsement from them or Trader Joe's
yeah man shout out to Coolio too you
know I got some smoothies and stuff
inside Whole Foods I don't you know I'm
kind of got my money in so shout out to
Korea what's the brand Koya they do the
keto shakes right yeah yeah those those
are gas you know my folks what's better
Whole Foods or Trader Joe's Whole Foods
okay and then you got everyone out here
I mean wait what's heroin you know
everyone this is like this is like the
god of the grocery store it costs a lot
it costs a lot and only there's
something you should know about me I'm
really cheap I'm a Ralph's so me I'll be
at Ralph's I'll be clipping the digital
coupons
I make sure I put my number in get the
discount get my fuel points up so when I
go to the gas station I get like 20
cents off per gallon Whole Foods I only
go into the return things I bought on
Amazon I no longer want it's crazy